Janet Yellen is the current treasury
secretary and the former chairwoman of
the Federal Reserve System she recently
came out and said inflation is way too
high in fact it's unacceptably high now
we just got the data from June of 2022
and inflation has come in at 9.1 percent
this is a 40-year high something that we
haven't seen since the early 1980s now
not only does Janet Yellen believe that
inflation is unacceptably high or
dangerous level but she also believes
that the Federal Reserve and the
treasury are doing everything they can
to help bring inflation down in a recent
speech Yellen had many interesting
comments here's an excerpt of that
speech inflation is unacceptably high
and that's something that's evident from
Wednesday's report I believe it's
appropriate that it's our top Pro it
should be the top priority to bring
inflation down the labor market is
currently very strong we've witnessed
and historic recovery and employment
we've now regained all of the private
sector jobs that were lost the labor
market is tight and the labor market is
in good shape
we are first and foremost supportive of
the fed's efforts what they see deemed
to be necessary to get inflation under
control and beyond that we're taking our
own steps that we believe will be
supportive in the short term to get
inflation down particularly what we're
doing on Energy prices the Strategic
petroleum Reserve also uh the work that
we're doing to Institute a price cap on
Russian oil to avoid potential future
spikes in oil prices now there's three
things that you Ellen highlights here
that I think are interesting the first
is that inflation is too damn High the
second is that unemployment is near a
historic low and the label Market is
tight and the third is that the United
States is trying whether successfully or
not to use their strategic reserves to
help get oil prices down now at the end
of the day the economy is a complex
machine one organization like the
Federal Reserve or another like the
treasury and even our elected officials
none of them have a magic wand all of
the inputs go into prices exploding
upwards Supply shocks demand shocks
loose monetary policy geopolitical
conflict all of these different aspects
of the global economy are coming to a
head now 9.1 percent inflation is
unacceptably high the average American
family cannot continue to withstand this
acceleration of prices and whether we
believe that the Federal Reserve and
treasury are doing everything they
possibly can or not I don't necessarily
Envy their position it's a
situation if they continue to raise
interest rates aggressively and they
conduct quantitative tightening they
risk pushing the US economy into a
recession if they don't act inflation
will continue out of control high
inflation or a recession pick your
poison and if we're really unlucky then
we will get both in a bout of
stagflation listening to Janet Yellen
someone who's been involved in monetary
policy and macroeconomic Theory across
the United States government is
interesting because it gives us an
insight into how people in her position
are thinking both about the economy and
what various organizations can do in
response I don't know what the answers
are but I know that 9.1 percent
inflation is bad news and I also know
that if they continue to aggressively
hike rates and conduct quantitative
tightening we will go into a recession
stay safe out there my friends and make
sure you're paying attention